tonight the mother of a woman allegedly
killed by her boyfriend opens up about
how the warning signs of domestic
violence can sometimes go unnoticed she
spoke with victoria saha hoping her
daughter's story will help save another
victim victoria
lakia lashawn dawkins family tells me
she was murdered in her sleep by her
boyfriend one week ago tonight as it all
happened while her five-year-old
daughter slept right next to her
25 year old lakia lashawn dawkins best
known by family and friends as kia i
shouldn't be planning a funeral for my
daughter
she should be planning on for me and now
her mom has to question why her
daughter's life was taken so soon at the
hands of her boyfriend who she was
dating on and off again for five years
that's a lot of emptiness inside me now
dawkins lived with her five-year-old
daughter and sister on the evening of
march 10 reshonda mikandici got a call
from her daughter saying dawkins
boyfriend shot dawkins she worked up to
the sound of the gunshots after
realizing what happened her other
daughter immediately hid inside the
bathroom police identified the suspect
as 25 year old danielle greer she pulled
the sheet back and saw that and she
caught she started screaming called
9-1-1 and ran and got my granddaughter
greer took off and while police worked
to track him down it was revealed that
greer was arrested in september for
domestic battery and had other criminal
charges for some reason she saw
something in him mcd urges any victims
of abuse to know the warning signs
if
any man even yells at you the wrong way
he's bound to do other things that's
where it starts grier was found dead
inside a hotel two days later police say
he shot himself suicide
that was the easy way out
my daughter had to suffer
so i felt like he needed to suffer
her mother really wanted to get her
daughter's story out there today so no
mother has to go through the same pain
and suffering dawkins five-year-old
daughter is safe and with family right
now if you or anyone you know is a
victim of domestic violence there is
help out there we have a list of
resources up on our website at
8newsnow.com victoria saha live local
now